[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
nous allons revisiter une actualité très
chargée au compagnie de jean baptiste du
père bonjour vous enseignez maître de
conférences à l'université de versailles
saint quentin à côté de vous je tiens un
peu comme hans kossmann berdych et
joséphine j'ai dit quoi josiane josy
films originaux c'est forcément mieux
vous êtes maire de plaisir vous êtes
vice présidente de la communauté
d'agglomération vice présidente du
conseil départemental à côté de stéphane
manceau pour les diversités de
versailles et saint quentin
on est ravis d'accueillir une certaine
bezina vous êtes aussi maître de
conférences de droit public et de droit
constitutionnel tout à fait celle du
droit constitutionnel est un garçon qui
ne connaît pas bien le droit qui avait
dû à la politique jean charles lajoie
dit bonjour bonjour on joue alors on va
peut-être commencer par une actualité
qui s'est déroulé cette semaine sur les
trottoirs de 50 ans qui étaient les
voeux traditionnels de la casse qui au
delà des voeux c'est vrai que on a
un téléphone qui sonne et on a surtout
une sorte de remue-ménage dans les
pouvoirs
d'abord il ya beaucoup de pouvoir y
aller mais riga la communauté
d'agglomération il ya le département il
ya aussi une réunion avec tous
les dirigeants des départements qui
avait lieu la scène musicale tout
récemment y en a on a l'impression tous
ses pouvoirs sont en train de bouger et
ça crée évidemment des inquiétudes et
c'est à vous que ça pousse cette
question j'ai fait une
un avis qui est plutôt un avis du vécu
une vie vaut puisque j'étais à la scène
musicale avant-hier soir et il s'avère
qu'on a un ressenti véritablement de
besoin de transformation au niveau tu
t'es des territoires puisqu'on a toute
une série les mille feuilles qui montre
là avec non seulement une
incompréhension de la part de la
population mais je pense nous aussi
aujourd'hui les élus on a une vraie
problématique puisque on ne comprend pas
très bien on comprend plus très bien où
sont les compétences des uns et les
autres et je crois que pour une
efficacité
il est plus qu'intéressant plus
qu'important aujourd'hui d'avoir une
visibilité plus grande alors on entend
parler de deux changements
constitutionnels on entend aujourd'hui
toutes ces discussions qui ont lieu
entre le président de la république et
gérard larcher pour ne pas les citer
puisque je sais qu'il y à une rencontre
qui a été je dirais un petit pas vivre
mais en tout cas avec une défense
bilatéral un peu différenciés mais
aujourd'hui on se rend compte qu'il y à
un véritable besoin de proximité et ses
besoins de proximité c'était la
discussion que nous avions au sein de la
scène musicale avec la défense en tout
cas des départements pour juste faire
une petite introduction sur le sujet
c'est dire que en réalité y ait
plusieurs projets ayant en effet il ya
la région ile de france il ya l'arrivée
du grand paris il ya les départements et
c'est vrai qu'on va arriver avec
peut-être plusieurs structures qui ceux
qui se font concurrence et donc on voit
plus très bien quelle sont les laits les
prérogatives et les pouvoirs des uns et
des autres une des problématiques
surtout s'est créé le fameux grand paris
qui active mis en place il ya quelques
années on comprend pas très bien on sait
pas très bien non on nous mêmes malgré
tout je dirais les fréquentations de
réunions de conférences de tables rondes
et a pu y avoir on ne comprend pas très
bien ce qu'on se rend compte en tout cas
c'est que c'est une valorisation de la
ville de paris et de la petite couronne
et un abandon assez
assez significatif de la grande couronne
dont nous faisons partie et on se rend
compte par des décisions qui sont des
décisions pour ne citer qu'eux 50 orne
yvin parle de la disparition par exemple
d'alaigne la ligne 18 qui avait été je
dirais accepté et acté par lindt agne
qui aujourd'hui 18 heures majorées loi
ou la ligne 18 qui va jusqu'à maniére
mozart en passant par ubi en cours et
c'est à une véritable structuration de
voirie nécessaires surtout dans le cadre
des jeux olympiques qui doivent arriver
en 2024
à partir de là on s'est rendu compte que
il était peut-être intéressant de voir
si on pouvait avoir effectivement une
métropole mais une métropole régionale
c'est à dire que l'île de france
aujourd'hui existantes qui est qui je
dirais une en eux une structuration qui
fonctionne pour la fin qui fonctionnent
sont là contre la dirige bien mais en
tout cas qu'il fonctionne à partir de là
peut-être que la strate d'en dessous et
pas forcément je dirais le le grand
paris avec la petite couronne mais ça va
bien au delà on a une puissance
économique qui d'ordinaire sur l'île de
france pourquoi recréer le grand paris
avec la petite couronne la région les
départements les collectivités et les
intercommunalités
j'ai bien compris ce serait d'avoir
paris et les départements limitrophes
qui ferait qu'il ferait une structure et
puis il y aurait les autres départements
un peu plus éloigné la région on sait
plus très bien quelle serait sa temps
son importance et sa et ils sont pouvoir
là dedans c'est vrai que voilà il ya un
bouleversement des structures
administratives quoi il ya des
compétences qui ont été jeudi révolution
en place mais qui sont en train de muter
de changer donc c'est très compliqué il
ya une vraie nécessité de re
compréhension mais surtout je crois le
les départements qui sont autour de la
petite couronne sont des départements
qui ont un impact fort qui font partie
de l'ile-de-france
il est impensable qu'aujourd'hui on
puisse les abandonner et ne pas imaginer
que il soit dans cette dynamique à la
petite couronne aujourd'hui est une
couronne très jolie res est très protégé
par paris paris aujourd'hui fait sortir
complètement je dirais les autres
prise de paris devient plutôt un lieu
touristique dit par ici les voitures
sorte de disneyland désert paris bientôt
mais il restera quelques boutiques y
voilà durée 1h ailleurs des choses
intéressantes je crois que ce qui
intéresse surtout les gens enfin qu'il
nous écoute c'est au-delà des
compétences auxquelles personne ne
comprend rien visiblement des uns et des
autres non mais non mais ce qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est de savoir
comment on va pouvoir se transporter
d'un endroit à un autre et c'est ça qui
intéresse les gens c'est le transport et
les la qualité de vie après sa voix les
entreprises qui est qu'ils peuvent
justement baissé cela c'est par l'emploi
il ya largement c'est parce que si on
veut tout le travail et l endroit pour
pouvoir y aller et c'est donc c'est ça
qui intéresse plus que les les quand
même les rapports entre des
intercommunalités
oui quels pays vont les 18 c'est quelque
chose de converser directement mêlé ça
veut dire c'est vrai que on a toujours
cette question de ce que vous habitiez
tout le monde appelle le millefeuille
administratif on n'arrive pas à refaire
de nouvelles structures
vous vous qui êtes élu local et qui
était dû départementale vous vous dites
que le département c'est quelque chose
de tout à fait nécessaire aujourd'hui
écoutez le département a comme
compétence prioritaire la solidarité
avec rsa avec tout ce qui est social
avec accompagnement au niveau de la
petite enfance
donc je pense que qui mieux que le
département peut accompagner jeudi toute
cette difficulté que nous avons
actuellement on ne le sait pas mais par
exemple dans les yvelines
le rsa est en progression rien de plus
on en a beaucoup plus donc on a
l'impression qu'on est un départ à leur
tour deux semaines plus tôt voilà oui
mais c'est pas le fait depuis deux trois
ans on a une véritable attention dans ce
domaine là je dis pas que le département
s'occupe des voiries et s'occupe des
collèges alors on pourrait les
distribuer autrement mais cette
proximité on s'en rend bien compte avec
avec avec les compétences dont je vous
parle c'est cette envie
j'irai une véritable action de proximité
que les gens ressentent aujourd'hui ce
qui est compliqué c'est qu'en tant
qu'élu local mais je peux vous dire un
politique
la première des choses que doit faire un
politique c'est de savoir ce qui se
passe sur son territoire quel qu'il soit
le maire les gens le connaissent très
bien et en règle générale il vient de
vous parler aussi bien des coccinelles
qu'ils ont sur leur terrasse que la
problématique je dirais de
l'enfouissement des réseaux sur une
coque donc on est on est dans cette
proximité le département a aussi ce côté
de proximité sur le social c'est un vrai
enjeu compliqué nous on fait de la
réinsertion aujourd'hui sur le
département
c'est un des buts premiers alors vous me
direz vous êtes conseillère
départementale c'est normal que vous
défendiez lipus deux départements mais
je m'aperçois et que toutes ces
transformations là ne tendent qu'à
retirer la proximité de l'élu par
rapport à la population et je crois que
c'est une erreur alors de restructurer
d'en supprimer
bien sûr mais il faut éviter d'en lever
cette proximité qui si importante à la
population c'est un vrai besoin
aujourd'hui on le ressent surtout avec
les problématiques que l'on vit avec eux
c'est pas de mention sur 7 sur ce
millefeuille c'est tombé sur moi
non les sept députés faire réformer
les a choisis les structures intéressées
ancien fond je vous rassure en fait je
voyais j'étais en train d'essayer de
faire de réfléchir dans l'histoire je ne
sais pas je suis remonté jusqu'à la
commune à la commune de paris 1871 en me
disant que depuis 1871 le les structures
administratives larchitecture
administratif de paris et de ce qu'on
n'appelait pas encore l'île de france
posait déjà question pour des raisons
essentiellement fait avoir purement
politique la structuration actuelle va
plus ou moins actuel de l'île de france
c'est 1964 c'est aussi pour des raisons
politiques qu'on a le grand département
de seine et oise qui a été divisé
département des yvelines notamment aînés
regardez ce qui se passe à paris maire
de paris à l'élection d'un maire de
paris et puis il ya une nouvelle
collectivité territoriale qui à compter
du 1er janvier 2019 va naître à paris ce
sera une collectivité sui generis qui
sera tout seul dans sa catégorie un
groupe de 1 mais donc c'est un
laboratoire qui est en perpétuel
mouvement un chaudron qui est en
perpétuelle ébullition ce qu'on parvient
à faire c'est qu'on parvient globalement
inventé et on est très fort dans ce
qu'on peut appeler l'ingéniérie
constitutionnel ou bureaucratiques mais
on parvient - à supprimer et madame
coleman ce berger le disait évidemment
oui le département des compétences
aujourd'hui qui sont importantes qui
sont exercées avec une proximité qui
peut confiner à l'efficacité
oui mais sauf que en effet si c'est pas
le département qui prend ça à sa charge
sera une autre collectivité a peut-être
un peu plus éloignés j'ai pas la région
la région toute façon on peut on la
réforme est mais on peut pas la
supprimer puisque c'est en gros
l'échelon de mise en oeuvre des
politiques européennes dont clichois
voilà il faudrait la commune la commune
ses complices et a su calmer chose que
pour une depuis la mise en oeuvre des
communes nouvelles
il ya une effusion comme jamais il ya eu
jusqu'à présent je vous rappelle qu'on
est tombé en deçà du seuil de 36000
communes
ça faisait des décennies qu'on n'y était
pas parvenu enfin je crois même qu'on
n'y est jamais parvenu on doit être à 35
mille huit cents et quelques est bon
mais il est hors de question évidemment
de supprimer la commune alors les
intercommunalités il ya aussi beaucoup à
dire sur cette métropole du grand paris
qui fonctionne pas et à laquelle
personne ne comprend rien ça en effet je
suis d'accord enfin la cour des comptes
elle même ne comprends pas au demeurant
comprend simplement que ça coûte un peu
un peu globalement globalement mais ça
coûte mais je crois même que les les
élus du grand paris ne comprennent pas
grand chose
oui à s'irriter de cette passe de ce
match on m'aurait dit le général de
gaulle donc mais c'est sans fin voyez
cette histoire de mille feuilles on se
on se gave de de crème de gagner de
feuilletage et caetera et puis on va
voir de vraies solutions enfants d'avoir
degrés celsius allison paris il ya il ya
une puissance du pouvoir central
hirvo cybernétique car il ya toujours
une méfiance du baril n'est pas la
franchise avec paris
intéressant dans ce qui a été dit c'est
cette idée de se préoccuper d'abord de
son de son territoire elle est
précisément le vrai problème c'est que
justement tous les territoires se
recoupent un petit peu à partir du
moment où on parle de d'intercommunalité
deux départements de région et et même
de grandes communes ce qu'on a en paris
qui s'élargit donc du coup on sait plus
bien quelles sont les frontières et ce
qui est intéressant quand on l'étudié au
niveau de la législation et de la
législation constitutionnelle c'est que
finalement comme le disait stéphane plus
on a voulu simplifier plus on a
complexifié voilà est donc en fait on
rajoute des structures en essayant de se
dire qu'elles vont petit à petit
supplanter les autres mais finalement
ils ne font que se superposent et donc
il ya ce problème de la suppression et
peut-être des nouveaux ajouts qui ne
cesse de
d'arriver dans le paysage législatif les
métropoles dont on parle et c'est une
des structures les plus récentes qui
était justement censé aider à ce qu'on
puisse essayer d'éviter des concurrence
avec les départements peut-être même
supprimer les départements et la
question c'est celle ci sait quelle sera
la structure la plus efficace est ce
qu'il y aura un courage politique de
tête d'essayer de faire quelque chose
pour que les territoires correspondent à
quelque chose de rationnel et le
suspense en parler dans la prochaine
édition
on verra aussi on attend le on attend la
décision du conseil d'état sur la fusion
entre entre le département des yvelines
département des hauts-de-seine aussi oui
oui à mon avis est mal partie 1
je le sens pas bien ça fait comme je
crois que c'est que je reste à 100 pas
bien j'ai l'impression est bon c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que il ya eu une
réflexion sur sur la métropole et que le
sujet a été intercepté voilà mais en
même temps juste de mousse pour vous
dire que même si la fusion n'a pas été
acceptée par l'état
nous travaillons nous dans des fusions
et au niveau des voiries au niveau de
l'archéologie au niveau de l'un autre
sujet j'aime reviendra mais on est
véritablement en train de fusionner dans
l'intérêt justement de faire des
économies en ligne et d'être beaucoup
plus efficace dans cette utilisation
donc nous on a commencé il peut y avoir
de politique commune sont forcément ce
truc est salée pour les communes qui se
rapprochent intéresse je dirais pas
besoin de faire une révolution alors
pour se mettre ensemble et plus efficace
c'est peut-être un peu le sens aussi à
mon avis de tout ce qu'on voit comme
errements dans la législation et dont
dans nos réformes c'est que finalement
le législateur est peut-être moins bien
placé qu'un élu local de terrain qui
s'il a envie de coopérer avec une
pelouse tout à fait le faire avec les
moyens juridiques qu'on a on en a pas
deux mais on aime bien
ou bien on aime bien complexifier le
faire en temps quand on veut simple
puisque vous donc été expliqué tout à
l'heure que vous saviez des difficultés
donc par rapport de responsabilité sur
les compétences qui sont attribuées aux
collectivités ou aux jeux pc y est c'est
vrai que nous même juriste à la faculté
comme enseignant donc il est assez
facile donc de décrire un petit peu ce
que disent les textes sur les
compétences des communes des
départements des régions des opci
mais lorsque les étudiants nous pose la
question de savoir si finalement c'est
compétentes sont pas plus ou moins
transversale se recoupent et comment les
abus tout place on est dans l'incapacité
totale de réponse et je suis rassuré
d'avoir que les praticiens du droit que
nous commentateurs voient la rixe et et
la deuxième chose c'est que en général
effectivement ce qu'on constate aussi
c'est que tout le monde est d'accord
pour réformer mais que finalement et je
ne prends pas un otage en particulier
mais il est vrai que youtube
chacun souhaite malgré tout préserver
les compétences qui sont les cierges et
voir vieillir et c'est la raison pour
laquelle moi je suis toujours
pessimistes sur les prochaines réformes
territoriales je crois que le mille
feuille territorial sera voilà une tare
française qui restera le et là je crois
longtemps à voir
livres bâtie le meurtre d'un président
de région d'un président assassiné par
l'assassinât on va en série que ça peut
se résoudre une bonne régulation
[Rires]
j'ai vu avec quelle véhémence je parlais
du département où 100 passionnés mais
dans tous les domaines c'est bien ça le
voilà je viens travailler avec vous je
vais être passionné de la même façon
mais les gens qui vous abordez vous à
bord de plus comme maire que comme
conseillère générale comme maire c'est
le meneur de la première bien sûr bien
sûr comme maire si cette proximité
qu'est le site était d'ailleurs c'est la
fonction autant il ya une défiance des
français vis à vis de la politique
les maires sont quand même
les mieux aimer si je veux dire oui ça
passe effectivement les gens ne votent
pas pour un maire parce qu'il est elle
partie sur une ville ça n'a rien à voir
c'est plus par le résultat j'ai tout ce
que c'est ça qui fait là l'importance de
l'élu c'est puis ça plus que sa couleur
politique hors média moche c'est comme
ça que je conçois en tout cas alors
parlons d'une autre force politique
c'est celle de ministre avec la sphère
darmanin voilà un ministre qui est
accusé de viol par une femme afin de
faire un peu compliqué lui-même a porté
plainte pour dénonciation calomnieuse
il y a dans des partis politiques par
exemple
wauquiez qui demandent sa démission
d'autres disent maintenant il ya aucune
raison de démissionner tant qu'on n'est
pas au moins mis en examen sans sable
ben oui moi aussi je trouve ça toujours
un peu choquant de bafou aussi
allègrement la présomption d'innocence
et c'est valable pour tous les gens quel
que soit le leur couleur politique
laurent wauquiez qu'il ne pouvait pas
antipathique par ailleurs il sort pas
grandie donc pour vous non mais c'est
pas ça mais c'est par esprit
démocratique mais j'aime bien qu'il a
les jambes droites et les gens de gauche
et des maquereaux nice to see donc
mais non il sort pas grandie du fait une
partie de la droite qui est furieuse que
des gens de droite hier il est parti des
républicains a d'ailleurs sinon voilà
qui est correct mais un lac liquide qui
ont rejoint macron alors du coup donc
donc je trouve pas ça normal du tout de
réclamer la démission de darmanin s est
totalement scandaleux
alors il ya bien évidemment des gens qui
font le parallèle avec bayrou et sylvie
goulard mais c'était pas pareil parce
que bayrou il gênait macron
politiquement donc c'est donc s'étonner
non mais on peut émettre une hypothèse
les gens sont étonnés de deux poids deux
mesures ces saveurs poids lourds au
gouvernement c'est un poil ou enfin je
veux dire on ne l'a jamais je n'ai
jamais vu macron pleurer pour le départ
de bayrou excusez moi votre cv votre ami
bo est parti dans l'allée dans l'allée
dans l'allégresse du gouvernement
tout le monde était endetté ravi devant
san siro gouvernement il n'a pas été
retenu
j'avais imaginé dans votre pc alors que
là alors que darmanin tout le monde du
13 des dégoûts en jeu tout le monde aime
bien en tout cas au gouvernement ont
tout le monde dit que madrid elle quand
même j'essaie quand même par exemple
sylvie goulard qui est qui et qui a une
autre fonction aujourd'hui mais raconté
que depuis qu'elle a d'autres partis de
gouvernement n'a jamais été ni convoqué
par la police ni rien ne s'est passé
c'est à dire que ils ont démissionné sur
un soupçon et rien ne s'est passé depuis
ça fait quand même maintenant depuis le
mois de juin c'est quand même ça pose
quand même des problèmes alors on
travaille c'est vrai que je trouve que
il ya d'abord une il faut le dire alors
politiquement ils n'ont pas le même
poids sûrement mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
quand même une forme d'inégalité dans ce
qu emmanuel macron avait installé dans
justement son style présidentiel en
prévoyant un petit peu on l'avait
pressenti la différence peut-être alors
beau françois bayrou est moins politique
que le fait qu'il était lui même
ministre de la justice ce qu'il a posés
vous poser des problèmes c'est vrai que
ça a été en effet de contagion ou aussi
c'est à dire qu'on a eu le sentiment
pendant longtemps que emmanuel macron
elle est interprétée la fameuse
jurisprudence balladur il veut que
normalement six mises en examen voilà on
avait le sentiment qu'ils allaient
anticiper cela et que à n'importe quel
bruit finalement qu'ils allaient courir
sur l'un de ses membres du gouvernement
eh bien on serait gentiment poussé vers
une fonction autre est ici donc on
inverse la donne puisque on attend la
mise en examen pour que ça se passe donc
c'est un peu le problème d'ailleurs de
cette fameuse jurisprudence balladur
c'est que on l'appliqué à géométrie
variable parce que finalement on a des
gens qui partent avant d'être mis en
examen et qui finalement ont des
non-lieux
on a des gens qui attendent d'être mise
en examen et c'est difficile de savoir à
partir de quel seuil on estime que la
confiance entre avec la charge les
oreilles hamas et on a tu vois présent
faire des 207 une mesure de protection
des libertés c'est pas du tout quelque
chose qui qui qui donne un faisceau de
présomptions contre quelqu'un pense
qu'il faut pas oublier cette analyse
c'est que aussi darmana s'inscrit
vraiment dans l'histoire de balances ton
port et demi tout où tout le monde est
dénoncé et sur mesure
une rumeur on lance des noms qui apprend
on voit ce qui se passe ce n'est pas ça
je fais pas ça les fait sourire ou
historiques voilà donc darmanin sais
c'est vraiment en c3 qui sont informés
plus le stade au moment de sa nomination
d'ailleurs au gouvernement voilà un pour
cent que pour ça que que la ferme ne
prendrai pas d'autres proportions là
dessus celui-ci je dirais qu'il est
assez récurrent depuis quelques temps
c'est cette attaque moi je me positionne
en tant qu'élu c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
les élus on est quand même un petit peu
coincé 1
il faut qu'on fasse attention est ce que
l'on dit à ce que l'on mange est ce que
l'on achète ce que l'on met je
caricature à peine on est donc selon
surveillance totale l'impression qu'il
ya un peu moins de liberté quand même
oui et puis et puis aujourd'hui surtout
je dirais pas très bien vu un être élu à
une époque c'était plutôt très
valorisant aujourd'hui lui raser les
murs je vous le dis pas du tout pour
faire pleurer sur les dans une chaumière
mais c'est vrai et donc au jeu tout ce
qui fait l'actualité qui peut être un
peu croustillants qui tourne autour d'un
élu est pris alors jeu via le juridique
bien sûr qui s'inscrit dans tout ce que
vous avez dit je suis complètement
d'accord avec vous mais il ya une
justice à deux vitesses mais il ya aussi
tout ce côté là ce côté ah oui ça y est
on a chopé quelqu'un on va y aller
et puis derrière on se dit mais alors
qu'il a dénoncé forcément c'est untel
c'est l'autre ah mais non ils veulent et
je les gens de droite veulent désiré
parce que vous avez vu il nous a fait un
enfant dans le dos de loi du pays près
de la violence politique et tout ça
donne donne une image de la politique
est qui et qui est assez désolante
après bien sûr qu'il est qu'ils soient
coupables ou pas c'est pareil ce soit
chose mais il ya aussi ça et c'est très
prégnant aujourd'hui alors au niveau
local d'une ville mais même et vous le
voyez bien au niveau bien sûr de l'état
c'est encore pire mais ça prend toutes
les strates sans en avoir conscience
nous on sait plus très bien les élus
comment se comportaient aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir
je dirais redorer un petit peu notre
blason parce qu'on est on est on est
beaucoup qui travaillons beaucoup et qui
sommes là aussi pour servir
bon ça y est j'ai fait pleurer tout le
monde n'attend plus que la vie de
marlène schiappa sur le sol et s'excuser
compliqué parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya
une catégorisation juridique et puis il
ya l'aspect politique c est ce qu on
peut rester en fonction et gouvernés
quand on est
soupçonné par an sans prime minister
qu'à partir un cintre soupçon ça veut
dire que vous voyez ça veut dire que
n'importe qui en france peut s'il le
souhaite on le décide en faire qu'un
ministre soit destitué de ses
responsabilités c'est absolument
impensable du point de vue de la
stabilité même de me sèye ministériel et
nos institutions en général je serais
même d'ailleurs plutôt favorable à ce
qu'on puisse pénaliser ceux des citoyens
qui dans l'intention de nuire ferait des
accusations oui donc à la mer vis-à-vis
d'un membre du gouvernement
compte tenu de la spécificité de la
fonction justement de cette personne qui
peut face après aux proportions
politiques peuvent prendre même un
détail insignifiant même si à la
présomption d'innocence
ça joue effectivement sur la mentalité
sur sur l'image de nos institutions
j'ai donc tous d'accord en ce même qu'il
ya un risque c'est vrai que la justice
un peu comme vous dis-je il est soit un
petit peu sous les projecteurs pendant
la période où la personne est en cours
de mandat et où finalement ensuite les
procédures ralentissent donc du coup on
a un risque aussi pour ça c'est vrai que
ça ça affaiblit nos élus et ça affaiblit
l'image de notre justice au sein de la
sphère fillon c'est vrai qu'on n'a
toujours rien de on a l'impression que
ça ça s'est accéléré au début le le parc
est fixé et s est saisi il ya une bonne
offre mise en examen et puis après ces
longs alors c'est probablement au long
d'enquêter sur ces affaires comme ça
mais c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression
qu'il ya une accélération à un moment et
puis après ça prend son temps quoi ça
pose des problèmes
enfin parce que c'est évidemment le
début de la sphère qui compte c'est de
la justice et de la politique qui
justement vous c'est un sujet dont voilà
un an depuis le 19e siècle on n'a pas
trouvé au comment régler leur relation
parce que précisément on a le sentiment
que c'est une catégorie qui du coup fait
partie des élus dont va être très
protégée et parfois même on a certaines
garanties comme la cour de justice de la
république qui va peut être mourir
à mon sens il serait temps mais on a le
sentiment qu'ils sont très protégés et
bizarrement au moindre à la moindre
menace
l'image est déjà un petit peu affaibli
et donc du coup la légitimité politique
elle même devient affaibli et donc le
personnel politique est à la fois plus
protégés est beaucoup plus vulnérable
que qu'un simple particulier donc la
justice à deux vitesses finalement on
l'a on la regrette mais est ce qu'il
faudrait mieux pas que ça soit le cas et
que y ait une catégorie plus protégés
peut-être en se disant les ministres
dans ce cadre-là serait trop vite
destitué faut trouver un bon équilibre
entre sept jours facile roman
d'anticipation dont l'aïe est la sphère
qui est un peu semblable est un peu
différente
c'est celle du président de radio france
mathieu gallet qui lui a été condamnée
en première instance et assez fortement
condamné d'ailleurs alors le problème
c'est que la ministre de la culture
avait demandé son départ que cette au
csa de décider s'il doit rester en place
ou pas et que le csa alors dans le sera
le ministre il soupçonnait aujourd'hui
d'être aux ordres du gouvernement
et il l'a fait il a fait appel mathieu
gallet donc quand on fait appel on est
quand même toujours présumé innocent
donc appel
oui c'est non mais c'est extrêmement
curieux fait de juger les questions sur
sa culpabilité alors qu'il est présumé
je disais parce que de la part du csa
ont parlé tout à l'heure de la mise en
examen là il ya plus que mise en examen
du ski une condamnation en première
instance
d'accord
je pense et fait courir est en quelque
sorte la motivation est assez
intéressant c'est quoi le csa était un
peu coincé en dix ans vont quelque part
on ne sait pas s'il ya condamnation ou
pas respectons la présomption
d'innocence mais il n'y aura plus de
sérénité dans ce mandat et donc il faut
faire quelque chose donc c'est vrai
notamment mois la motivation juridique
de la décision savoir quelle est cette
nouvelle idée de la transparence et
l'inde ont tous logis qui a servi à
prendre cette décision
elle est très fuyante à mon sens je
comprends pas forcément pourquoi le csa
tout d'un coup a voulu ériger cette
moralité comme une valeur importante du
mandat mais en tout cas il est prudent
en essayant de dire la présomption
d'innocence est préservée mais c'est le
bruit qui a couru qui va lui coûter sa
place il y avait de plus avait dit la
ministre a demandé elle a souhaité oui
moi j'aimerais prudents parce que oui
pas facile d'exprimer voilà est-ce que
exactement non mais est-ce que je me
dise où doit s'exprimer là dessus
sachant que en principe les prisons de
l'audiovisuel sont nommés par le csa que
nous y allions n'avons plus parait-il
aura coupé le cordon ombilical entre le
pouvoir et la nomination d des
présidentielles donc est ce que nos
ministres avaient le droit de souhaiter
quelque chose non mais c'est bien pour
ça le mot ce truc qui devait souhaiter
c'est un ordre le souhait c'est pour
perdre et ça me je ne sais ça dans une
position compliquée est-ce que soit il
se révolte est coincé le 16 ou alors la
seule solution pour le cs c'était de
maintenir
pauli qui dégagé en touche en disant
attendons l'appel et puis voyons la saq
se termine
dans un an oui bah donc habitants que la
moitié du temple de temporiser face à
derrick mitterrand l'a beaucoup défendu
il était au cabinet et directeur adjoint
du cabinet de fer avec 8 ans et 10 ans
que le csa aurait pu au moins mourir
avec l'honneur le le csa est
probablement condamné un terme c'est
qu'il y aura encore une réforme mais là
aussi on sait depuis la la la haute
autorité en 1981 la cncl s'était enfin
tout ça tout ça va et vient ça serait
vraiment bien comme disait je ne sais
plus quel philosophe claude françois non
c'était pas faire appel à vous référer
mais n'étaient pas seuls thermique mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des raisons en
réalité ça n'a pas beaucoup changé à
l'autre le cnc elle le sait une petite
évolution depuis le vertex comme un oui
enfin je pense à l'excès mais c'est très
amusant parce que on parlait tout à
l'heure des au fond de la
recentralisation peut-être vis-à-vis des
départements ou dvd des poids il semble
qu'on revienne peut-être alors tf dans
le projet de réforme c'est à dire que
regrouperait la radio la télévision et
on est je pense que les gouvernements
aussi beaucoup de mal des frères ce
monstre et qu'on va peut-être leur faire
enfin pour des raisons économiques
aujourd'hui mais souvenez-vous de
sarkozy qui disait c'est une hypocrisie
et une bronze il ya un organisme
supposément indépendant qui nomme mais
en réalité il est sous influence ou ce
devoir exécutif donc c'est moi présent
un public qui vais nommer les copains
comme ça s'est toujours fait je sais pas
si ça c'est une bonne
une bonne façon de cesser ça a été
compliqué parce que du coup il n'a pas
nommé qu'ils voulaient c'était c'était
parce que la critique et guy la porte il
l est
il en a pâti et et sans avoir pu nous on
pourra exercer son pouvoir
le millefeuille audiovisuel est une
autre noniste alors qu'il qui intervient
beaucoup c'est votre ami tient pas alors
ça c'est à lui de le faire avait déploré
la mort de sa femme et on a appris
ensuite que cette règle est qu'il avait
provoqué semble-t-il enfin après tout
tout cas il a avoué présomption
d'innocence mois fin et alors c'est vrai
que l'avocat de ceux de jonathan d'aval
a invoqué des violences qui auraient pu
être commises par son épouse sur lui et
marlène schiappa jugé cette défense
scandaleuse là aussi
moi il me semble que depuis poniatowski
qui avait dit mme ofran au bon moment de
deux de la sphère du petit garçon
assassiné et je souhaite la peine de
mort il n'y a pas une ministre comme ça
qui interviennent dans une affaire
judiciaire non bbc tout ça tout
allemande déplacer et s'élève dans la
sphère privée mais quasiment incroyable
quelqu'un ministe permettent comme ça de
d'abord de sur-réagir on ne connaît
visiblement pas le les pièces du dossier
que nous ne connaissons pas non plus n'y
en a pas accès au dossier d'instruction
n'est pas des avocats ont eu un rôle un
peu curieux d'ailleurs
l'un comme l'autre mais voilà que sept
ministres se permettent d'attaquer la
système de défense du du présumé
coupable enfin will 900 je sais pas ça
paraît tout à fait tout à fait
scandaleux et bon après c'est à l'aise
ils se placent sur le sur le fait de
duels maintenant le fellini féminicide
qui est une catégorie qui n'existe pas
en droit de vote il en présentant c'est
à dire en effet le le fait que une femme
meurt sous les coups de son mari de tous
les trois jours en gros puisqu'il y en a
une centaine de 120 femmes ce roi qui
m'a fait me chercher c'est tuer une
femme parce qu'elle est une femme est
vraisemblablement s'est construit par
ici prochaine le rythme est la sienne et
moi dans cette affaire ce qui m'a aussi
c'est aussi la réaction de castanet
reçurent donc manier n'ya pas donc qui
questionnaire qui l'a recadrée en disant
qu'une ministre n'avait pas à intervenir
dans le domaine de la justice et je
trouve ça assez curieux du point de vue
des rapports entre ministres qu'un
simple secrétaire d'état prennent tout
d'un coup la fonction de premier
ministre
le patron du parti en marche oui mais
alors alors oui mais oui oui et alors
mais alors c'est pas rien c'est une
ambiguïté puisque est-ce qu'il
intervient en tant que collègue en tant
qu en tant qu homme voilà où en tant que
président du parti
voyez enfin je trouve que à ce constat
illustre à ce moment là justement
l'ambivalence de la double fonction
on avait évoqué dans un précédent
position des luttes étaient à tout le
moins préférable qu'il indique à quel
titre vous pensez que l'on réduit rien
dire c'est que vous me disiez quelque
chose on n'est pas d'accord
non je pense que c'est aussi au premier
ministre ses palaces parisiens il ya
cratères datant parfois en application
d'une règle constitutionnelle c'est le
principe de solidarité ministérielle qui
veut que un ministre est solidaire des
actes et de la parole qui est porté par
ses homologues et que le point
d'intervenir
donc vous voyez là quelque part la
fonction de président de parti il
empêche
enfin le plus tôt sa fonction de
ministre l'empêchent d'exercer
pleinement la liberté que pour avoir un
président de parti pour critiquer
quelqu'un qui est de la même famille
joséphine que je voulais évoquer le fait
de ce qu'on a pu dire aussi il ya
quelques mois sur sur ces ministres qui
sont arrivés au pouvoir et même certains
députés qui sont quand même très hors
sol avec peut-être une incompréhension
de la société civile qu'on voit là il
méconnaissance du fonctionnement
j'aurais plusieurs exemples à vous
donner / je dirais des députés que que
je côtoie aujourd'hui j'ai un profond
respect de la démocratie
mais avec je dirais un mode de
fonctionnement
on sent bien qui est en apprentissage et
il ya quand même des collyres même des
règles il ya quand même un mode de
fonctionnement quand on est il eu
quelques je pense que là par rapport à
cette marlène tu peux me permettre ça
eh bien je crois que si ça c'est une
erreur on va dire de jeunesse une erreur
je dirais de voyage parce que elle se
place sur un autre point de vue qui est
pas le point de vue judiciaire qui est
le point de vue de la défense et des
secrétaires d'état aux droits des femmes
et éduquer le point de vue de la défense
des femmes
et elle elle parle d'ailleurs de deux
victimes bla ming maintenant c'est à
dire que on charge la victime alors cela
dit ça c'est triste c'est une procédure
habituelle fondre dans les procès pénaux
j'ai toujours intérêt à le charger à
victimes quand on la connaît le coupable
c'est la jurisprudence jacqueline
sauvage
c'est à dire que ça on va voir elle
avait tué son mari ont des rues c'est le
mari qui était un donc elle a eu
raison de le tuer bon ben là c'est
effectivement donc on peut comprendre
que marlène schiappa soient choqués
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya des choses
cependant fait deux d'un coup de dire
bah oui mais enfin si cette femme
oui mais finalement était pas si sympa
que ça elle devait tracer horripilante
va bientôt on va dire bah oui et de
l'action c'est pour ça qu'il est
peut-être un peu léger heureusement
qu'on n'exécute pas toutes les personnes
un peu exaspérant
il y aurait autant de réponses que vous
parlez de chapa et où papa plein
d'autres côté très sympathique très
efficace elle s'exprime bien donne une
image je trouve assez renouvelée de la
politique justement parce que elle fait
pas toujours attention elle n'est pas
allée pas dans la langue de bois c'est
parce qu'elle est conne losc est assez
agréable
donc ça c'est plutôt plaisant quand il
sort les longeurs ces mauvais si mais ça
veut dire que les banques comme moi
j'apprécie beaucoup cette liberté
qu'elle prend et 7
ce ton qu'elle enchaîne en règle
générale je me permets de temps en temps
de temps en temps de dire là elle a tort
vous n'êtes plus sensibles à la ministre
ou à la femme
ah oui je ne sais pas si je vais
répondre en tant que maître de
conférence en tant que femme en tant que
représentante de la femme sur le plateau
de ce côté je fais attention justement
il faut peut-être aussi qu'on se libère
un petit peu des différents quotas
canton quand on prend la parole et c'est
je crois que c'est à la fois le charme
de marlène schiappa c'est qu'on a le
sentiment qu'elle a un petit peu réagi
par coup de sang alors après c'est vrai
qu'elle est une conception assez
extensive de son office plusieurs fois
la saisine csa pour des propos qu'elle
avait pu entendre et qu'il lui
paraissait déplacés par rapport à sa
conception de la femme
alors je ne sais pas si en tant que
femme je me sens concerné par tout les
propos sur les femmes et s'il faut à ce
point-là défendre les femmes et de
manière absolument universaliste comme
elle elle leur sang c'est un point de
vue je ne suis pas sûr qu'en tout cas un
ministre est à se mêler d'une affaire
judiciaire moi c'est un peu ça qui me
qui me gêne et le dernier point que
j'aurais aimé avancer c'est que voilà
réfléchissons en termes d'affaires
judiciaires c'est la justice qui
travaille et je trouve que la procureure
de la république l'a bien rappelé hier
dans sa conférence de presse en évoquant
la présomption d'innocence et surtout un
principe de secret de l'instruction que
moi je trouve de plus en plus mise à mal
ça avait été le cas pour la faire fillon
c'est le cas également
avec cette affaire d'aval où on peut
dire qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
suite
il ya beaucoup de bruit c'est un peu
l'effet bfm c'est à dire qu'on a des ddd
nouvelles toutes les minutes d'une
affaire qui est en cours et je suis pas
sûr que la justice puisse bien
travailler dans ces conditions
dernier mot aussi sur l'avocat de la
défense un avocat défenseur avec ce qui
s'est passé avec la sphère abdelkader
meira aussi je trouve quand on tape un
petit peu facilement sur le défenseur
c'est aussi son rôle
c'est le principe d'un procès pénal de
dire voilà chaque équipe un peu un peu
difficile et puis voilà l'avocat de la
défense il a son rôle pour les droits
fondamentaux pour c'est vrai que au sens
alors là on le voit sur une affaire
judiciaire mais on pourrait en parler ou
en politique cet effet bfm s'était fait
un faux continue qui fait qu'il faut
toujours fournir des choses et qui fait
que alors tout le monde ne parle plus
que d'une chose vous ne parlez plus de
cette affaire pendant pendant laquelle
vous re après on va l'oublier
on va passer à autre chose mais il faut
occuper l'espace jeunes quand on est
quand on est élu ou quand on est dans
une responsabilité politique et même au
delà il faut occuper l'espace sonore et
de la manière la plus brève possible et
on a rayé la rai et le président de la
république
c'est une expression était peut-être
malheureuse en considérant comme
monsieur le président la république
avait une pensée complexe et qu'il était
très justement difficile de pouvoir pour
lui s'exprimer en quelques minutes et
quelques secondes mais ça n'est pas faux
sur le fond d'ailleurs comment voulez
vous la vie est complexe
la réalité est nuancée je trouve que
l'intelligence se situe dans la nuance
alors comment voulez vous être nuancée
en jeu c'est pas une quarantaine de
secondes où on vous tend un micro et on
vous dit votre analyse sur la question
nous on se regarde le signe sur un tweet
ou en 140 signes sur la toile ou voir
même pour nous en trente mille signes
dans une revue juridique c'est parfois
très court espace compris de surcroît
donc c'est un cri
nous essayons d'écrire des fils goût de
l'article les espaces cela dit il faut
pas oublier aussi enfin quand même que
c'est une histoire passionnante et qui
intrigue riche plus on n'a qu'un but
pendant trois mois ce type éplorée
effondré en larmes dans les bras des
deux de ses beaux parents etc puis
maintenant tous les gens qui s'étaient
apitoyer qui était plus faisait des
marches blanches presque des quêtes
c'est tout vu ce n'est pas une cagnotte
ulule ou je sais pas quoi trucs
participatifs pour l'aider à surmonter
cette douleur et puis bon maintenant on
est là on découvre que c'est méchant de
nuisance adultes que c'est le méchant de
l'histoire et c'est la colombe donc ça
va nous remplacer un petit peu jeu
plaisant busan dans l'histoire quand
même le
le tweet de jean marie le pen vol à vue
non là l'upg n'est pas bonne et jean
marie le pen a tweeté je pense qu'ils
n'étaient pas seuls ils devaient avoir
un petit ami
[Rires]
c'est pas que dans la subtilité
jean-marie si tu es si tu nous explose
après nous en tant que citoyen a le
droit de s'exprimer
parfaitement c'est vrai que moi ça mais
ça m'a fait penser à une autre avec
avait été très médiatisée qu'avait été
la sphère bertrand cantat marie
trintignant ou là vraiment pour le coup
le programme ariane schiappa on aurait
été plus à propos puisque c'était
vraiment une violence faite à une femme
en tant que femme est bon on a aussi
quand même quelqu'un qui a réagi presque
sûre et qui a appelé en disant voilà bon
il s'est passé une discuter ça a dérapé
là on peut y croire alors que c'est vrai
que là avec ce scénario qui consiste
déjà étranglés par accident c'est ça
serait difficile à prouver
alors sans intention de la donner
justement donc là c'est vrai que ça
paraît déjà un peu absurde et toute la
suite c'est à dire que ce qui est très
aggravant c'est la scénarisation d'un
apprêt ouvre vraiment on n'a pas le
réflexe de quelqu'un qui peut avoir une
remise de peine parce qu'il a réagi en
voulant sauver sa femme le plus vite
possible
non bien au contraire il a essayé de
jouer le mari éploré ça je pense que ça
va faire campagne a pas eu de maisons
soient là ya pas une mise en scène à
cannes mis un peu de temps après une
bonne dizaine d'heures
ah non laps de temps ça mais ça fait une
nouvelle ère est confrontée comme ça
vous serez meurtrier à ce que à moins de
la vie on n'est pas à l'abri d'autres
révélations dans cette affaire c'est
jean charles qui a brûlé le corps voilà
un petit ami par exemple alors qu'il ya
toute une famille il ya plein de gens
voilà donc je pense que on nous cache
des choses mais on nous cache rien la
justice travaille dans une certaine
sérénité en tout cas on espère
répliquant l' on n'a qu'à attendre
on a le temps judiciaire que vous
connaissez bien pour l'éditeur et
l'éditeur polar que vous êtes
est-ce que ça pose des problèmes parce
qu'au fond on se rend compte qu en
qualité comme on dit est parfois plus
fortes restrictions non et ben oui en
tout cas ça se rejoint parce que on sort
un livre où nos débuts début mars ou
d'un type ce qu'on dit un petit peu un
petit peu de cette façon la terre qui y
rentre chez lui et il trimballe le
cadavre d'une femme dans sa voiture et
le laisse comme l'a fait visiblement
enfin apparemment le jeune nathan il
laisse le câble de sa femme dans le kop
toute la nuit il repart le lendemain
avec de la promène un peu il donc voilà
ça se rejoint effectivement comme rêver
ci s'appelle du placement de produit
reste qu'il est là car pour eux c'est ça
je n'ai pas donné le type d'huile
d'apple je serais le dernier un david
coulon est ce que les gens s'intéressent
plus à la réalité au crime heures vente
et ben en tout cas ils sont passionnés
ils sont passionnés par la passion
qu'ils ont montré là dessus est ce que
ça veut dire que je pense que les gens
sont passionnés par le roman policier
parce que c'est un des genres avec le
réal avec le roman jeunesse qui se vend
le mieux donc ça c'est incontestable
mais après comme ils sont passionnés par
les faits divers et on l'a enfin on est
tous cas moi je le suis c'est vrai que
je fais tout journal tous les matins je
regarde tous les faits divers c'est moi
même avant d'être éditeur de romans
policiers notamment se trouve c'est
toujours intéressant c'est que vous vous
y intéresser aussi beaucoup vous avez
écrit dessus de tout le monde est
intéressé parce que ça ça révèle
beaucoup de la société de2 de ce qu'on
vit de ce conte de ce qu'on craint de ce
qu'on traverse donc voilà alors le vrai
fait divers mais il est passionnant mais
effectivement dans un roman bas on a
toutes les clés en 250 pages on n'attend
pas quatre ans ça qu'il ya toujours
cette énigme des criminologues et qu'est
ce qu'est ce qui fait que certaines
passent à l'acte c'est la question que
vous en parlez je suis beaucoup plus
passionnant encore ce sont des élections
partielles avec l'une de nos collègues
qui qui est candidate sortante dans le
dans la première circonscription du val
d'oise du val d'oise ce niveau là qu
isabelle muller quoi qui est maître de
conférences en droit public à la faculté
de droit damien mais vous êtes partout
nous sommes partout
l'éducation nationale au ministère de la
justice est très bon et reconnu pour ses
la vengeance des publicités nous avons
mis quelques siècles la cma faut dire
non aux armes oui nous y voilà
on a eu la duke tête la dictature des
publicitaires et maintenant on verra la
dictature des publicistes alors il y
avait aussi le territoire de belfort qui
concernait pas et alors on a à peu près
le même schéma c'est à dire que la
république en marche et l air se
maintiennent à peu près et on note un
effondrement à la fois du parti
socialiste du front national et à celle
de l'extrême droite et du ps
oui le tout avec quand même avec
beaucoup d'absences avec une abstention
femmes et 20 % et ce cas la situation
change beaucoup de choses dans l'oeuvre
que vous pensez ben oui probablement
c'était probablement que parmi les gens
qui s'abstiennent y avait des gens qui
votaient socialiste où il y avait des
gens qui votent front national
mais est ce que c'est on peut tirer des
conclusions d'une d'élections partielles
comme ça à après un an des
présidentielles où on me connaît enfin
le nom mais on peut dire oui parce que
sa propre voix l'a nommé en parler
henson que non non ça montre quand même
le problème auquel est confronté comme
le parti socialiste et je suis pasteur
les noms des candidats comme premier
secrétaire permettent de le sauver moi
je pense que ça veut quand même dire
quelque chose surtout vis-à-vis du parti
socialiste comme un à partie avec une
qui avait une base militante très forte
des gens qui étaient très impliqués et
très passionné et c'est comme vous le
dites si sont restés chez eux c'est
quand même très révélateur et 2 je crois
que ces deux et demi pour cent des voix
enfin c'est oui c'est tellement triste
d'effondrement enfin c'est vraiment
c'est ce qu'on voit dans d'autres pays
et d'ailleurs en europe le sale temps
pour la social démocratie parce qu'on a
ce qu'on a appelé pendant des années la
social démocratique note révisée
d'ailleurs ce concept mais oui oui là
c'est on air on est dans le
transnational dans leur sphère
globalement dans un phénomène qui touche
qui touche presque tous là avec des
proportions quand même assez assez assez
mais regardons intéressant c'est que
avec ses mains je pense aussi aux
prochaines élections partielles qui vont
avoir lieu en mars
c'est que la recomposition politique est
quand même en marche et que l'on voie y
compris au sein du parti et l'air une
scission à cnet qui commence à se
dessiner avec notamment donc alain juppé
qui n'exclut pas pour les prochaines
européennes de faire alliance avec wilde
tron et lui dit ce qui soutiendra des
candidat es les rues m
modem aux prochaines élections
partielles donc on sent qu'il ya un
basculement une recomposition qui se
fait et qui est un petit peu de
nouvelles à droite puisque on raisonnait
encore en bloc avec l air en disant
c'est un parti de gouvernement qui reste
à peu près préservé
compte tenu de l'arrivée d'emmanuel
mâcon pouvoir et son nouveau parti donc
là effectivement ça continue de bouger
mais c'est vrai que la stratégie des
républicains elle est compliquée face à
de stratégie parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'autre stratégie nous semble-t-il enfin
je peux me démontre que celle que j'ai
choisie wauquiez c'est à dire d'aller à
droite non mais sinon c'est aujourd'hui
c'est un peu ce qu'on ressent tout cas
je tenais à ce jour même temps
compliquée c'est en tout cas le mot est
juste c'est une stratégie
oui surtout un taudis véritablement
ressenti sur le fait d'aller je dirais
récupérer un petit peu ce qui ce qui
aujourd'hui est en déperdition
alors peut-être pas chez les socialistes
mais en tout cas de l'autre côté c'est
ça qui crée véritablement la scission
aujourd'hui au sein dlr puisqu'on a
qu'on a des camps je dirais beaucoup
plus à droite beaucoup plus radicaux et
puis des camps qui s'exprime aujourd'hui
étant sur une côte est beaucoup plus
social et démocrate la leur c'est l'été
s'était il faut bruit c'était comme le
rassemblement des centristes de la
mairie tout à fait tout à fait et au
sein même de des grands comptes et de
tension vlr il ya des temps on voit pas
lire des tensions mais en tout cas il ya
des réflexions de réaction langue de
bois mais aujourd'hui on se cherche on
le sent bien mais quand vous parliez du
parti socialiste tout à l'heure moi je
croise énormément de gens qui me disent
non le parti socialiste n'existe
n'existe peut-être plus en temps de
partie mais mais la philosophie
alors voilà je mets en cause mais là il
cherche à se reconstruire en tout cas
est ce qu est ce qui est encore la place
une philosophie socialiste pour un parti
de gauche enfin qui ne soit pas le
schizo enfin pour parti socialiste qui
ne soit pas le parti de gauche justement
le mélenchon alors c'est vraiment ce que
je trouve intéressant dans cette
recomposition dont on parle depuis tout
à l'heure c'est que souvent on se
focalise un peu sur l'idée qu'il n'ya
plus d'opposition et qu'on ne sait pas
qui est dans l'opposition parce que bon
il ya cette nouvelle marche qui est en
marche mais la question c'est finalement
je crois que c'est pas tant important
pour nous de connaître notre position
que de connaître notre majorité et c'est
vrai que du coup le lr a pendant
longtemps on ne savait pas trop dans
quoi ils aller naviguer c'est vrai vous
parlez de la ligne radicale de wauquiez
qui en ce moment est la plus audible
évidemment mais moi je regarde beaucoup
les déclarations des groupes justement
qui sont affiliés donc au parlement donc
nos groupes sont obligés de nous dire
sur quoi ils vont travailler et quand
vous lisez la déclaration des groupes lr
à l'orias est allé constructif et il ya
les autres mais la philosophie est aussi
de se dire bon parfois on pourra suivre
la majorité on n'a pas forcément de
ligne arrêtez donc c'est plus dur dans
le discours que ça ne l'est dans la
pratique en tout cas de nos élus
parlementaires qui s'autorisent à être
un petit peu au milieu des deux donc la
majorité très composite ça va dépendre
du vote de certaines lois ça peut
dépendre des tec ça peut dépendre des
moments donc on est vraiment dans
quelque chose d'assez volatile et pour
répondre à votre question sur parti
socialiste c'est justement dans quelle
optique sur quelle loi dans quel projet
est ce que ça va être la justice est ce
que ça va être quand on va parler de la
réforme constitutionnelle qu'une
identité de gauche va peut-être se
réveiller c'est peut-être à ce moment là
qu'on pourra reparler de du ps mais
c'est vrai que pour le moment on a du
mal à savoir 1,6
dans la vème république 1 1 une
personnalité oui mais ça me saoule
écuries les plus optimistes droite non
mais justement mais même mais maman il
ya quand même besoin d'être incarné non
par quelqu'un ou pas est ce que est ce
qu'on s'est posé la question peut se
poser la question de se dire est ce que
la population aujourd'hui ressent le
besoin de retrouver cette opposition
face à cette opposition de droite gauche
surface je caricature mais parce qu'on
en a pas assez au fond de soi ou alors
il ya eu toute une période avant les
élections pendant pendant la préparation
des élections où effectivement on
sentait qu'ils en avaient ras-le-bol de
tout ça tout le monde en avait assez et
finalement quand macro est arrivé on a
eu l'impression de rentrer dans une
espèce de sérénité on va dire tout le
monde s'entend bien emprunt puisqu'il va
bien droit quand il peut bien gauche on
met tout ça dans le même panier
et puis que tous ensemble on va
construire la nouvelle france très bien
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs
à tel point que même les politiques ont
dit bah attendez on va pas donner un
chèque en blanc non on va quand même
regarder je crois que vous avez raison
c'est exactement ce que ce que les gens
attendent
me voilà à laissant leurs ils ont les
ont toutes les manettes ils ont tous les
pouvoirs il avait envie de changer le
monde en tout cas de changer la france
ils peuvent le faire qu'ils le fassent
et et attendons c'est effectivement
assez sain d'un médecin si les résultats
sont là oui besson ça fasse tout le
monde sera ravi si ça fait si ça
fonctionne c'est ce qu'on souhaite tous
mêlés donc lorsque vous l'avez cette
addition jean-charles donc
dommage collatéral
c'est très bien ce sujet les élections
européennes seront importantes et sur le
plan européen et sur le plan national
parce que c'est peut-être que le ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure
la recomposition va continuer à se
mettre en marche
et bien voilà c'est sur ces mots cette
conclusion assez centriste un petit que
le verrou n'aurait pas assez ça conclut
obernai je termine cette émission merci
merci beaucoup à tous d'avoir participé
que vous reprenez évidement tout ce que
vous voulez merci beaucoup merci bad pas
tout de suite quand même
[Rires]
[Musique]